thank you very much can you hear me so
it's really a pleasure to be here first
time and also he's a speaker so double
bench I'm professor at Imperial College
so I work on different topics in machine
learning and today I would like to talk
about deep learning on graphs right so I
guess in this community I don't need to
advertise deep learning it had long and
bumpy history maybe under different
names but I think in the past several
years it has changed quite servers quite
a few industries and markets and
academic communities in particular if
you look at computer vision and image
analysis you can see that deep learning
has had a profound impact on this
community and now they basically
everything is based on deep learning in
computer vision now if we look at the
main focus of research in in depending
it has been mainly focused on data or
kinds of data work we can call them
Euclidean basically there is some kind
of underlying grid structure images are
a very good example they can be
represented as two-dimensional greens
all your signals one dimensional grids
and so on and so forth but we also in
many cases need to deal with data that
doesn't have this grid structure we can
call it non Euclidean probably social
networks are the most prominent example
these aircrafts were gnomes represent
users and edges represent social
relations right and basically there are
other examples of data that can be
modelled as a graph you can think of it
almost as a ubiquitous model for any
kind of relations or interactions
between stuff right so on you can find
it in biology you can find it in brain
imaging you can find it in computer
graphics application where you can model
maybe slightly more complicated
structures meshes you can represent
three dimensional objects so bottom line
there is really need there is a lot of
applications across a broad spectrum of
domains where we need to deal with this
new type of data ok so just to give you
an example of a few applications and
different sorts of applications that we
can encounter in these contexts so I
think something happened to me yeah so
this is an example of a graph that
models a molecule right so atoms will be
nodes and chemical bonds will be edges
and we want to extract some features
that predicts certain properties of this
molecule for example if you are in the
business of drug design we want to
predict whether this drug will be
efficient whether it will be toxic
whether it can be dissolved in water and
so on and so forth right so basically
given a graph we want to to classify
this graph right so if we take an
analogy make an analogy to some problems
let's say in computer vision this is
like object classification right I want
to tell that this image it contains a
cat another type of problems our vertex
wise classification for example if we
are in the social network and we have
some let's say demographic data about
the users we would like to predict the
way they voted in the past elections
right so again an analogy the computer
vision it's like semantic segmentation
you want to label each pixel in the
image whether it belongs to a background
foreground whether it's person car etc
right we can also distinguish between
settings where we have a fixed graph
like in a social network at least at
some snapshot of time the network is
fixed versus applications like in
computer vision in graphics were
basically they domain changes so if we
model three-dimensional objects as
surfaces or as graphs basically each
object comes with its own graph right so
we want to train our models on a
collection of such graphs and then apply
them to previously unseen ones and
finally we can also distinguish between
settings where the graph is known and
given like a social network versus cases
where the graph is latent or maybe
partially known or noisy so we want to
learn not only some features on this
graph but also the graph itself okay we
want to reconstruct there are many
applications especially in biological
and Natural Sciences okay basically what
we are trying to generalize to graphs
are
convolutional neural networks so
conversional neural networks is probably
most of you know more very successful
paradigm that is working very well in
another analysis of images in text
analysis and speech analysis so
basically roughly speaking it consists
of two basic operations these are
convolutions and pulling operations
conversion you can think of it as a bank
of filters basically sliding window that
you run through your image and the
coefficients of this filter are
learnable and you determine them in
optimization procedure that is called
training and pulling just down samples
usually in a nonlinear way the image so
it basically somehow averages or takes
maximum of blocks of pixels okay so
basically this way create a hierarchical
representation of your image and in
terms of computational complexity it has
a fixed number of parameters per filter
so it's independent on the input size
you can run it on very large images and
the complexity is linear so it scales as
order of n where n is the number of
pixels input size okay so the question
is how do we do something like this on
graphs and if in images or in general on
grid like data it is very easy on image
you can think of writing a sliding
window throughout the image how do we do
it on graph right basically how do we
generalize convolution to graphs so I
don't have unfortunately a lot of time
so I will show you just one recipe I
will just mention that there in the past
several years so this is relatively new
topic and machine learning actually the
origins of tip learning on graphs are
pretty old probably about 10 years old
by machine learning standards it was
before the deep learning hype but let's
say all the modern methods that are
currently used her probably from the
past two or three years so we wrote the
first three view paper on this topic
last year I would say it's already not
up to date there are several follow-up
papers that that are more up-to-date and
contain some of the more recent stuff
and this field is evolving extremely
fast
okay so this is a graph and let's say
that we have some data on the graph so
we'll represent them as D dimensional
features so you can represent it as a
matrix of size n by D okay and basically
this graph has vertices and edges let's
assume for simplicity that the graph is
undirected or the edges call both ways
right
and basically we can define an edge
feature function so I remind you that we
want to do some kind of filtering
operation on the graph so on the graph
and like an image you know you had each
vertex you might have different number
of neighbors so basically what you can
do we can take pairs of your vertices
right or features at the vertices
denoted here as X I and X J you might
also have age features that encode
information about relations between the
vertices so if you think of social
network for example this can be this can
capture some communication between users
in some way okay so and basically we
have an edge feature function parametric
function implemented usually as a small
neural network that basically takes this
triplet of things right so the vertex
and the edge features and produces some
new set some some new feature vector
that is then aggregated now another
thing that is important to know about
the graph unless you provide some
outside information there is no
canonical way of ordering the vertices
in your neighborhood right so basically
it should be locally permutation
invariant right so this aggregation
operation usually it will be a summation
or a maximum but in general what's
denoted by this square operator can be
something else maybe even something
learn about right so we aggregate this
information we get a tree realization of
a convolution you can actually show that
the standard convolution on images can
be implemented as a particular setting
of this more general operation okay so
this way you get a new set of features
that could be a potential of different
dimension at each vertex of the graph so
what is important this is a local
operation it can be computed in a
distributed way so there are many ways
of making it efficient and paralyze etc
we can also so you can think of it as
kind of nonlinear operator acting
the fishes from the of the vertex of the
vertices and the edges and producing a
new set of features we can concatenate
these this operation several times so we
can for example write it in terms of
some function that is privatized by
another set of parameters that is
applied to these two these features and
basically what we get is some kind of
local learn about nonlinear operator
okay so an example of such operator
probably everybody's familiar here is
the laplacian operator graph laplacian
operator so what operation does it
Everage --is in some maybe weighted way
the features in the neighborhood
vertices and then subtracts the value of
the feature at the central vertex itself
and does it for every location in the
graph okay so basically you can
interpret convolution in terms of in the
spectral domain basically looking at the
eigen functions of this laplacian and
you can implement filters using some
applying some functions of this
operation for example a polynomial
filter will be just taking powers of the
operation so you can think of it as a
kind of a diffusion process that is
controlled by these coefficients of the
polynomial okay so this is an example of
a very simple polynomial filter on a
graph so in this case the graph is just
agreed so you can see how it looks like
it has radial symmetry that comes from
the permutation local permutation
invariance of the vertices okay so there
are some other settings where the graph
actually is represented in some
euclidean space so it's an embedded
graph basically each vertices can be
associated with some coordinates okay in
this case if you have a local system of
coordinates around each vertex we can
assign a set of weights in the system
coordinates and these weights allow us
to average locally the values of the
features in the vertices so you can
think of this as a kind of
generalization of pixels so in a patch
in an image these weights will be just
selecting the first pixel the second
pixel and so on in a page this is
something more general okay and
basically this way we can generalize
convolution in a slightly different way
it would be a spatial organization of
the conversion we call these page
operators okay now about pulling
basically pulling essentially it
essentially amounts to progressive
coarsening of the graph so for example
one simple way is to collapse edges
connecting pairs of vertices and
basically this way you have two vs.
become a single vertex and for example
you can do the standard max pooling that
is using convolutional neural networks
just taking the maximum of the feature
pictures in each of these pairs of
vertices okay so bottom line you can
represent it as a tree structure and
pooling basically works more or less the
same way as it works in images okay so
let me talk a little bit about
applications I think applications are
really exciting because I said in the
beginning crafts can be applied to model
practically anything so you find
applications of craft neural networks
really across the board so applications
for example in point cloud analysis this
is very now very interesting especially
in the domain of self-driving cars for
example you can see a car that drives
with a lighter sensor so it sees a 3d
world around it and it has to detect
objects or segments do signetics
semantic segmentation for example tell
apart the road from pedestrians right so
these are some examples of semantic
segmentation of objects well in this
case these are synthetic objects but the
results are extremely accurate so the
input here is a point cloud this is
something slightly more interesting so
these are scanned indoor environments
okay and these methods can be applied to
large-scale scenes that can contain
millions of points so this is another
interesting application so this is I
don't know if you have seen it probably
so these are intriguing properties of
convolutional neural networks that boil
down to the fact that the meting from
the input to the output is very non
smooth so basically they can be fooled
by what is called the adversarial
perturbations essentially you can modify
very minutely the input image and make
the neural network from
that classifies your images to classify
it incorrectly so imagine that you have
a self-driving car that has a neural
network that is trained to recognize
traffic signs if I put some stickers on
this traffic sign in a certain way I
will be able to fool the network so
instead of stopping the car it will run
at full speed and will kill somebody
right so maybe a little bit apocalyptic
example but at least in principle it's
possible so even more weird examples you
can change one pixel in an image in a
data dependent way obviously so I can
touch one pixel in this cat and the
conversion on your last work that is
trained almost perfectly to recognize
different objects will recognize it not
as a cat but as a bird okay
and even more worrisome so all these
examples are a data dependent so they
the way that the perturbation is
designed depends on the input you can
design even the universal perturbations
so give me your neural network as a
black box or a gray box I will be able
to design a single perturbation image
that when added to the input and it's
almost impossible it will change the way
that the neural at work classifies it
and you see that you see some slight
perturbation but it's almost invisible
right in nevertheless the neural network
classifies this image incorrectly okay
andrew is a zillion of different ways of
designing these these perturbations
under different conditions I don't have
time to go into it and some cool
examples how for example face
recognition systems can be fooled by
specially designed glasses that you can
put on and the convolutional neural
network recognize you as somebody else
okay so basically what what does it have
to do with graphs basically the idea is
we we call it peer nets so it's
basically the regularization layer in
standard convolutional neural networks
whatever you like whether you like
residual networks or something else
whatever whatever you want
basically we inserted somewhere between
the standard conversion and pooling
layers and basically the this
regularization layer takes
features from neighbor images right so
basically you don't consider a single
image like in standard commercial
neurotic but you also exploit the space
of images its genetic structure and
these genetic structure is encoded as in
a form of a graph so it's a kind of well
kind of averaging in a special way in a
low number way of your neighbors and you
can see that it significantly improves
there about the robustness of neural
networks against this kind of
adversarial perturbations and well I
will skip some examples but here is the
kind of the kind of noise that falls a
standard neural network this is the
amount of noise and also you see that it
is much more structured that is required
to fool the peer vapourized neural
network so basically it's not anymore
imperceivable okay another application
somebody mentioned netflix in the
beginning so i guess everybody knows
netflix right so netflix is probably one
of the canonical examples of a
recommender system they even run a price
of 1 million dollars for improving their
results basically you have a huge matrix
of users versus movies right and each
user gives a score to a movie right but
of course we have only limited lifetim
so we can watch that many movies
basically this is a very sparse matrix
right and they want to interpolate the
missing values they want to predict
whether a user would like the movie or
not right so they want to predict the
scores that the user have not provided
and usually it's solve this an algebraic
problem fitting some low dimensional
solution to the given data usually it's
done by minimization of some convicts
proxy of the rank function so you try to
find the matrix with the smallest number
of independent rows and columns that
explain the data usually it's it's an
np-hard problem so it's replaced by what
is called a nuclear norm so it's complex
proxy for the for the rank so bottom
line this algebraic formulation doesn't
have any genetic structure right if I
shuffle the rows and the columns of this
matrix I will not change the rank if I
have an entire column missing I can feel
it
in infinitely many ways so this is
problem that is called cold start when a
new user arrives with no scores given to
any movie basically you don't know what
to do with this user right so basically
what we can do is we can add some extra
information that can either come from
the data itself or maybe from some
out-of-band information from maybe
demographic features of the users so it
is a little bit naive model but it works
nicely in most cases so it assumes como
FIDIC relations meaning that if think of
this model so you have a social network
of users so the graph here represents
whether the users are related and you
can assume again maybe naively that
friends have similar tastes so now we
can explain these data in terms of
smoothness on this graph right so we can
say that if I move from one user to
another user I will find similar scores
so it's also a low dimensional model but
in a different way basically it can be
these metrics can be expanded in terms
of small number of population
eigenfunctions so bottom line we can
write it again as some kind of learn
about parametric diffusion operator that
takes our data defuser it and compares
it to the data and the only set of
parameters are these diffusion
parameters that are independent on the
input size so usually these are big hard
approximation problems here we optimize
just for the parameters of the networks
and if the chips at least used to
achieve about a year ago when we publish
this paper state-of-the-art results
actually similar methods have been
implemented in industrial settings so
Pinterest for example has a recommender
system that slightly different
algorithms but similar ideas that can be
applied to crafts with billions of nodes
okay so some applications from high
energy physics so this is the LHC Large
Hadron Collider
one of the biggest machines that was
constructed by the humankind basically
this is a giant ring that accelerates
particles so almost the speed of light
and banks them together and by banging
them together basically this kind of
particle Jets are created so basically
particles decay and create hundreds or
thousands of different other particles
that have different properties
and they're picked up by different types
of detectors and this is exactly what
these plot represents right and in LHC
because particles come probably millions
per second they detect such events with
very high frequency so this device
collects a lot of data and only most of
it is it's boring it's not interesting
so you can consider it is Earth noise so
they want to quickly classify some
interesting events that for example
might contain hints of some new physics
for example one the Higgs boson was
experient Lincoln firmed basically there
was some filtering information the
filtering stage that discarded most of
the events and left only the interesting
ones and if you think that LHC's is a
big device think twice so this is ice
cube this is the neutrino Observatory on
the South Pole and really this is
literally speaking the tip of the
iceberg because the detector itself is
carved into the ice so it's called ice
cube because it's cubic kilometer of
detectors and the detectors look like
this so these are bowls containing photo
multipliers when neutrinos are particles
that have almost no mass so they travel
from Astrophysical sources the long
straight lines or as straight as
possible by accounting for general
relativity distortions and usually they
don't interact with matter but in the
very infrequent cases they interact they
create this glow in the ice that in
physical terms is called chain curved
radiation bottom line it is picked up by
these detectors and the picture looks
like this okay so here you see event one
event is some noise and another one is
energetic Astrophysical neutrino coming
from some very distant object that is of
interest to astronomers and actually it
has it has been in the news several
months ago because it was the first time
that Ice Cube allowed what is called
multi messenger observation of a blazer
some mysterious center of some distant
galaxy that emits neutrinos probably
there is a black hole in the middle so
basically it indicated
to other astronomers where to look in
the sky okay and basically the problem
here is how to detect neutrinos so how
to take these interesting events so the
difficult part of these problem is that
neutrinos are extremely rare events so
we need here to work with extremely low
false positive rate most of the events
are background they should be discarded
so we have a very recent paper that was
presented just a few weeks ago where we
showed that we are able to beat existing
baselines with craft convolutional
neural networks in this case the array
of detectors is treated as a graph and
we even got best paper Awards for this
thing yeah thank you so another example
of application is from brain imaging so
in this case well basically if you have
multiple geometric domains so it's
interesting basically in this case we
have a brain that can be modeled as a
graph basically spatially related
regions in the brain you have different
patients that can be also related by for
example similar genetic background or
maybe similar disease history or even
gender so basically we have similarities
between patients and we also basically
the temporal axis where we measure the
response of the of the brain or
different regions in the in the brain to
different stimuli so these are
functional MRI signals and here there is
a plethora of different tasks that can
be addressed for example you can
automatically diagnose certain
neurological diseases such as
Alzheimer's disease based on these data
or basically try to better understand
how the brain works I will mention two
last applications so one of them is from
the from the domain of former civics and
computational chemistry or drug design
so I mentioned in the beginning
basically you have a molecule and you
try to predict its properties so the
usual way it's done well obviously can
do it by experiment but experient is
expensive and you cannot test billions
of candidates unfortunately the search
space for drugs is huge it's bigger than
the number of
atoms in the universe so usually you
already know you restrict this research
space by for example looking only at
molecules of certain size or molecules
that can be synthesized in the lab and
usually you do quantum mechanical
simulations now with convolutional
neural networks on graphs that model
molecules as graphs you can do at least
as good as quantum mechanical
simulations or a particular type of
simplified simulations called DFT but
about five sort of things faster so this
really opens new potentials for
commercial screening of new drugs and
materials and even more interesting are
the direction is generative models where
you try to basically start with a set of
properties and synthesize a graph or a
molecule that has these properties so
you probably have seen examples of
generative models for images where you
can synthesize human faces using for
example generative adversarial networks
so something like this for graphs is
very cool and still an open problem but
there are some results so these are all
synthesized molecules by molecular
generating networks you can predict side
effects in drugs so you can for example
instead of inventing new drugs and
designing new molecules you can use
existing drugs in different combinations
so this is called poly pharmacy and some
of these combinations are known most of
them are known so basically there is no
clinical trial that tells you what will
happen if you take process em all with
amoxicillin or something like this so
some side effects might be innocuous
some of them might be dangerous or even
little for some people so predicting
these effects is extremely important in
in clinical medicine you can also think
of protein based drugs where the drug
itself is not a small molecule but a
protein basically a specially-designed
protein that binds to protein targets so
the target here is actually also it was
in the news because the Nobel Prize in
medicine in 2018 was given for the
discovery of this program death
mechanism that is using
illogical immunotherapies so very
briefly speaking basically it blocks
certain proteins that signals to immune
system not to attack a cell and
basically immune system can destroy
cancer cells in this way by activating
this mechanism so we're able to design
proteins that will bind to these kind of
targets so potentially it opens avenues
for a new class of drugs that could
treat cancer I will finish with probably
the coolest application and this is fake
news detection so fake news are
everywhere as you know right
you open a newspaper and you don't know
whether it's true or fake so obviously
it's a big problem for companies like
Facebook or Twitter there is a lot of
empirical evidence recently that shows
that fake news spread differently on
social media and nowadays obviously
everyone especially the younger
generation uses social media as the
source of information so there was a
paper in science in the beginning of the
past year that showed that news on
Twitter propagated differently depending
on whether they're true or fake so the
problem is that it's very hard to
axiomatically determine what makes a
distinction between fake and through
news so what we can do we can learn
these features so basically we use
genetic deep learning the conversional
neural networks on graph to learn
specific patterns that allow to
characterize fake news and distinguish
them from real news so this is an
example of a small portion of the
Twitter social network and the car here
represents whether a user spreads fake
news or true news and the black lines
represent a cascade basically the way
that a piece of news spreads so this is
what we are doing in our startup fabula
and this is one second of shameless
advertisement which I'm not supposed to
do okay so I think I will stop here I
think it's a very cool and exciting
topic there is plenty of research going
on and some of the leading machine
learning groups around the world
including in our group at Imperial
College and there is a plenty of open
problems so yeah if you're interested in
research questions then especially
generative models or large-scale
applications of these methods are
extremely challenging and interesting
and obviously can try to apply these
kind of methods to your type of data if
it can be represented as a graph or
something like this okay so I will
finish here thank you very much yes you
are you are allowed an advert slide in
the middle of your world because you've
done a lovely talk that's we do allow
that sorry let's scale is any questions
Michael we've got me a couple coasters
for the break yes the microphones nearby
you will chair
yeah
so there are several implementations
well obviously our own implementation
for some of the algorithms but there was
a recent library from google deepmind
which I never use myself but I heard
that it's not great and there are
several other libraries so we also we
have a website that is called geometric
deep learning com so it has some
examples of cold references etc yeah but
basically the short answer there are
several implementations of some of these
algorithms so basically it's it's not a
single algorithm it's more of research
direction so there's many different
different approaches
so well these the graph theoretical
features such as centrality and
another's in principle you can learn
them basically with these methods the
issue with these handcrafted features a
centrality might be good and
discriminative feature for one
application and not good feature for
other applications so same way with deep
learning that you don't know a priori
what is important and what is a good
feature and what is not a good feature
you learn it from the data basically
driven by the task so same thing here
you might be able if centrality is the
feature that is the right feature for
your specific task then hopefully the
neural network will learn this feature
but it might be something else
[Applause]